Et yo tout le monde c'est Mickalow !
Aujourd'hui on se retrouve,
Sur le "Mâche Mots".
C'est un jeu de société.
EUHHH..
heuuuxx
Dans lequel on va avoir une gueule dégueulasse.
Donc dans quelques instants notre gueule va ressembler à la gueule de ces gens.
C'est-à-dire ridicule.
Voilà absolument.
En gros ! Dès que tu le mets,
Je lance le sablier.
Il y a un paquet de cartes devant toi,
T'en pioches,
Tu me les lis et si je devine la phrase,
Tu mets la carte devant toi et ça veut dire que tu as gagné un point.
"Faites glisser une aile entre vos lèvres et vos dents d'un côté de manière à ce qu'elles touchent l'intérieur de votre joue"
Ah! C'est bon!
"Ne mordez pas..." non, c'est bon, il l'a mit!
Oh le con!
*rires*
T'es sûr que c'est comme ça...?
T'es plus mon ami.
Vas y, tiens. Est-ce que tu es prêt Micka ?
Articules bien !
C'est parti !
"Un cha... *??*
*rire*
Quoi ?!
Un chiachant ?
Non, un chia...*??*
*rire*
Oh, ta mère... En qui...*??*
C'est impossible mec !
C'est quoi ?
Par les...*??*
Argent... ?
Nan... *rire*
C'est fini, c'est fini. Tu as zéro point.
Je suis prêt.
Le pire c'est par, mec.
Franchement, t'es beau...
*souffle de Dark Vador*
*rire*
Bo...
(Musique épique)
La vieille valise...
La vieille valise.
De pépé...
De chéché?
Est partie bouder.
La vieille valise de pépé...
La vieille valise de...tchétché...?
Nan!
La vieille valise de pépé est partie bouder!
De héhé.
De, de pépé putain!
Y'a mémé et y'a pépé! De pépé!
Bordel de merde!
Je trouvais pas pépé.
Bon, tu m'accordes un demi point vu que tu avais réussi à trouver un peu...?
Bon, ok.
T'es prêts? Top!
Moi.
Ouais.
???
Je rêve ?
Nan. *chante*
Bohème.
*??*
Souris ?
nan un *?* un *?*...
Un four !? un four !, moi bohème four ...?
???
*rire*
Y'a pas une difficulté "enfant" là dedans ?
*rire* Ok,
Les fourmis....
Les fourmis.
???
Opticien ?
Mais n*que ta mère !
*rire*
???
*rire* On dirait un mec qui parle en gogole !
En mission ! *rire* Mission Impossible avec Tom Cruise, bordel de merde !
J'ai pas compris...
Ok a toi 3..2..1..c'est parti !
Cette
...anane..???
Banane
Est
??? S: Vraiment
M: Une      S: Une       M: Bombe         S: bombe
M: ouais   S: Cette bannane est vraiment une bombe
MAIS CA VEUT RIEN DIRE BORDEL . Comment veux-tu que je devine ça ?
Ok vas-y vas-y continue continue
M: La vieille S: La vieille... M: Nan la veille
La veille... de la fête
de la fête... des mères
m'a bouleversé
Ville... Nan... Il...
Huile... MILLE! Le chiffre, connard!
*rire* Une? Naan!
*rire*
Bon t'as, hé deux cartes mec!
Mais toi t'as du mal, tu galères à comprendre
Mission, tout le monde avait deviné apparemment, on me dit dans l'oreillette
Allez! T'es prêt? 3, 2, 1, cette fois je te fais tout deviner, c'est parti!
Il arriva... pile-poil
*rire*
Six cheval!
Pile-Poil! Remplace les "feuu" (F) par des "fé" (P)
Par des "C"
Nan!
Tu me montres un "C" là!
Il arriva pile-poil à franchir la barre symbolique
... A franchir la barre symbolique
Voilà!
Il arriva... à cheval!
*rire*
Il arriva "pile-poil"
Pile-poil!
OUIII!!
C'est pas compliqué, les kchi (??), c'est des "P"!
Admets déjà que je me suis tapé le mot "pile-poil"
J'crois qu'y a pas pire dans la langue française
Mon
Bébé *en chantonnant*
*en chantonnant* Bébé
*rire*
Hé-hé! Waka-waka!
Mon... bébé?
Ouais!
Waka? Pourquoi tu dis waka?
Ok, mon bébé... fuck
Phoque
Marche vite, mon bébé phoque marche vite!
C'est fini, c'est fini!
Go!
S : Il fait...  M: Il sait
Faire... Il FAIT!
Il sait faire
Il... FAIT!!
(Musique épique)
*rire viril*
Il FAIT!
Aah p*tain!
Mais oui p*tain!
3, 2, 1!
C'est à force...
de forger...
que l'on devient...
pâtissier! (lol)
Forgeron!
Oui!
"Il a fait...
des pieds..."
De si
"Des pieds!"
Défier
"Des pieds et des mains!"
Décidément!
Des pieds et des mains, tu prends ton pied au *rire*
C'est fini! C'était quoi?
Il a fait des p.. *rire* des pieds p*tain!
Hey attends tu m'as mis bien là hein!
Tu m'as mis bien, cousin!
C'est parce que j'suis fort!
Redescends!
Quel frimeur formel
Et il pleure en plus
Fantastique!
Profite bien
L'hippopo...
L'hiHOHO
L'animal, l'animal!
L'hippopo, le truc rond
L'HIPPOPOTAME!
L'hippopo, voilà!
Place de la République
Répit
République
Répit!
*rire + bave*
Profite de l'hippopo répu
Repu! J'ai dit répu, j'sais pas pourquoi!
Attention, dernier round!
T'es à... 2, 3, 4, 5... T'es à 6 cartes
7! J'suis à 7 cartes!
T'es à 6 cartes, J'en ai 7, tout est possible!
C'est parti, TOP!
*incompréhensible*
Quoi?
Belle prise, monsieur le bouffon
Oui
Ok!
Infâmante...
Ville... Huile
Infâmante bile qui me prend (??)
Mais ville j't'avais dit ville
BILE! Mais même quand j'ai pas le truc tu comprends pas!
Fils de
Mais qu'est-ce que je me doute qu'il met de la bile?!
"Ton poème..."
Ton cheval
Ton poème! Un poème...
Ton poème!
OH OUI!!
"A été fabuleusement"
A été... salement
Fa-bu-leu-se-ment
"Promu"
Promu?
OUI!!
"Il forme ses muffins"
Le truc qui se mange!
Muffin! Un muffin!
En vain
OUI!!
"Ce boulevard"
Sans vouloir...
"Ce Boule..." *rire*
Ce boudoir!
Nan! "Ce boulevard!"
Boulevard Sébastopole
Le poudoir!
Ce BOULEVAAARD!!
Ce boulevard, ce boulevard!
J'crois qu't'as lâché de la grosse bave
J'm'en bats les c**illes, frère!
Le round ultime! C'est parti!
"Le biotope"
Le risotto?
"Bi-o-to-pe!"
Bio... Un yaourt qui est...
BIO!
"To-pe"
Toque? Tope? Toche?
Une taupe! une taupe!
Bio-taupe?
OUI!
"Du biotype"
Du iotique?
On nan c'est la fiiin!
Nan mais attends, c'est quoi cette phrase?!
"Le biotope du biotype se perd"!
Bon ben voilà, j'ai gagné qu'une carte Micka
Si tu gagnes plus d'une carte tu es le champion
"As-tu vu"
"Le fauve"
Le cheval!
Le fauve...
"Des faubourgs"
Des tambours
"Faubourgs"
Des chevours?
Faubourgs!
Des fau, des fau...bourgs?
OUI!!!
"Se faufiler"
OUUI!!
"Dans les phrases"
"Je vise"
"Avec des virgules"
OUUUI!!
Et c'est la victoire!!
On est champiooons!
Pourquoi tu jettes ce sablier?
T'as triché?
Nan!
C'est pour ça que tu l'as envoyé!
Nan nan!
On était arrivé au bout, tu me l'as pas dit, disqualifié!
C'est la fin du temps!
On a gagné! Team Squeezie, je savais qu'vous étiez avec moi!
Je l'savais!
Micka... Bravo, je t'offre... euuh
Bah cette perruque! J'ai vu que tu y as pris goût, je te l'offre!
Voilà! Hyper classe!
Nooon
Super!
Mm.. Non, non
*rire*
Bon, eh bah voilà les gens, c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo
sur le Mâche-mots
Et je trouve que tu es particulièrement fort à ce jeu!
Et je trouve que tu es particulièrement nul à ce jeu!
Finalement, comme à tous les jeux!
Exactement!
A bientôt, ciao tout le monde
Peace! C'était Mickalow!